qui sont là,
qui font preuve de courage, qui rassemblent les gens,
et d'inciter nos fils à s'identifier à ces héroïnes
et à dire, "Je veux faire partie de leur équipe,"
parce qu'ils vont faire partie de leur équipe.
Quand j'ai demandé à ma fille son personnage préféré de "Star Wars",
vous savez ce qu'elle a dit ?
Obi-Wan.
Obi-Wan Kenobi et Glinda.
Qu'ont-ils en commun ?
Peut-être qu'il y a plus que la robe scintillante.
Je pense que ces personnes sont des experts.
A mon avis, ce sont les deux personnes du film
qui en savent plus que les autres,
et ils aiment partager leurs connaissances avec les autres
pour les aider à atteindre leur potentiel.
Ce sont des leaders.
J'aime ce genre de quête pour ma fille,
et j'aime ce genre de quête pour mon fils.
Je veux plus de quêtes comme ça.
Je veux moins de quêtes où on raconte à mon fils,
"Va et bats-toi seul,"
et plus de quêtes où il voit que c'est son devoir de rejoindre une équipe,
peut-être une équipe menée par des femmes,
pour aider les autres à devenir meilleurs
et être de meilleures personnes,
comme le Magicien d'Oz.
Merci.